anyway so I'm going to talk about the
work i'm going to talk about
I'm a maker of comics and various types
of narratives my background is in
graphic design teach design history
applied semiotics design methodology
design design design right I'm also
interested in like social designer
designs around race around
intersectional identity politics those
types of interesting designs as well
right so I'm a start we're talking about
the idea of the cipher I decipher back
to hear right any hip-hop fans in the
audience sadly okay yes all right so so
you know the cipher is right your spark
a cipher it's a circle of rappers or
emcees who are playing off of each other
usually in a battle format right we're
trying to like show that you have the
best of bills get the best skills as MC
right there's also a circle right and so
I like this idea of thinking about the
influences that led me back to where I'm
now which is to a certain degree home
right so I'm gonna start at home I think
a lot about hip hop in home and
different types of like spatial
representations and I'm from Mississippi
originally a in this place called the
sticks in like often the cut and this
place called a floor Mississippi it's a
agrarian space about 15 miles north of
jackson this which is the capital
mississippi and so I'd literally grew up
in the middle of a cotton field like for
real like not even like the kind of
stereotypical ideas but like literally
in the middle of a cotton field and one
of my favorite things was to stargaze
actually I used to love to lay on a barn
I know it sounds very Andrew Wyatt's but
it's actually what I used to do and gaze
at the stars and think about my
connection to him and think about what
these other spaces are that are out
there right and when I was introduced to
hip-hop as a as a as a series of like
cultural making ideologies it came to me
through visual culture right through MTV
my first thing that I've watched was
Aerosmith and Run DMC walking this way
you know the anyway
I really love that stuff right but
because there weren't any like subways
to tag in the middle of a cotton field
somewhere right but I love the culture i
love the idea of hard function so call
myself a CJ so this notion of like
sampling andrey mixing rejects position
of ideas how these two different types
of making inform my practice the way I
look at like research that kind of thing
but i'll start it with uh technical
problems yeah I'm trying oh here we go
like all right with these individuals
right my grandmother and my mother the
first artist that I encountered all
right was raised by my grandmother my
mom she remade Thompson also known as
Momo everybody else called a big momma I
got a call to Momo Janie Mae my mom they
messed me up pretty good let me tell you
how so now looking back at my research I
realized that my grandmother probably
was a conjure woman she probably was
like she had these particular ideologies
and superstitions that i think would
directly connected to conjure culture
root work hoodoo culture that kind of
thing which has been influenced a lot of
the work that I've been doing fairly
recently my mother just liked really
cool stuff and she shared it with me I
pretty much grew up in grind houses you
know second run movie theaters anything
that was violent had a ninja in it we
were probably to watch it oh my god had
blood and ninja in the title we're
definitely gonna watch it right and we'd
have discussions about these particular
ideas and I think it's because I didn't
know my real grandfather at the time but
my mother's father was murdered right
and this is important for the lighter
for later on and violently and I think
and this is me just thinking back
through this stuff thinking about how
those stories deal with trauma or unpack
particular types of cathartic ways of
looking at trauma right and I think that
she was doing like conspicuous
consumption because we watched a lot of
horror movies it's probably stuff that I
really should have been watching but we
had like a long protracted conversations
about it you know so imagine like kid
growing up in the middle of the country
collecting like bugs and thinking about
stories
right looking at stars listen to a
hoodoo lady that's how I ended up in
this space right so the cypher starts
here right so recently a lot of my work
has been associated with what's been
called afrofuturism basically black
science fiction like speckle of cultural
production and it started with these
particular images I started thinking
about the fungibility of the blackbody
the replication of black stereotypes in
popular media and how they just keep
popping up I'm kind of a stereotype
hunter actually you know hunt them down
unpack them try to figure out what they
are how they function that kind of thing
so I was doing a I was on a the first
diversity scholar and residency at James
Madison University you know how they
after like slide diversity never so i
can get it funded you know that was the
first one though so i was there for two
weeks right and you get a show as well
so i went to do a show in japan i was
carrying the show over there and i was
really influenced by robots and how they
dealt with this idea of like the
constructed body or the dealt with this
notion of like how the how the black
body becomes like an extension or an
artifice is connected to colonialism
that kind of like the soft machine like
literally The Soft Machine and how like
when somebody created a cotton gin it
was really like an upgrade right oh we
can just throw that old technology we
have a new thing now right we're going
to do with these guys so anyway so this
this particular see this series is
called matters of the fact i named it
after france for noms de facto blackness
highly influenced by like Donna Haraway
cyborg manifesto as well but also
started looking at how if you're a black
cyborg and you connect it to a system of
oppression then maybe it's not so much
maybe it's not a good thing to be a
cyborg right so I started I thought
about this series for like about four
months and I just kind of simmered on it
there's 70 of these images I created
them in four days it was almost like
they just came out of me you know and
it's kept make them kept making
back-breaking I didn't get up you know I
barely rested i just made images right
and so they started talking about like
reappropriation of old images around
black
is systemic issues around oppression but
also how black people in America connect
to Africa through buying commodities
that aren't necessarily connected to
their actual tribe of origin or space of
origin but kind of represent an in do it
index kawai you know a connection to
Africa right and you sell that and we
buy it and sell that you know and so
this idea of the commodity of blackness
and and how these particular things keep
popping up but these are called matters
that affect it's like really black
cyborgs whist what kind of started
thinking about these ideas and one of my
friends was Africanist looked at which
is oh these afro futurists and I was
like you're making up words what is that
thing that you said by afro sweat you
know yet using afrofuturism okay so i
started doing research in that area
before you know it i was like okay this
actually is something that is a
motorcoach productions been around for a
while particularly you thinking about
like the idea of technology as an
extension of identity which i think is
fascinating so of course these are all
based off of stereotypes pushed jungle
bunnies and that's called Baker's burden
right so those those types of images but
again there's like 70 of these and this
is just like a snippet of one of the
things that was really interesting again
about it is like the the replace ability
to funds ability of the black body how
like one particular part could just be
like place for another during slavery
right and so that was actually part of
it as well the other thing I've been
doing a lot of is book cover design you
know I'm your book cover guy you know
I'm a I'm a trained as a designer like I
designed these books as well as like
helped put them together I'm really into
like book design material culture that
kind of thing and so I get tapped to do
a lot of book design so some of these
somewhat some of my colleagues are will
hit me up and i'll just do like a lot of
illustration work and that kind of thing
so practice wise i'm still at active
freelancer so i do like a lot of
freelance work dealing with like
promotional work usually around like the
black speculative idea
as far as like process wise i still do a
lot of drawing by hand as classically
trained as a my minor isn't drawing so i
do like a lot of figure drawing but also
do a lot of manipulation through digital
technology so i use photoshop
illustrator all the whole like creative
suite package right and also design my
own cover that's my collection as you
noticed I like sample my own work to the
idea of like sampling every mixing
something's really interesting to me
this was from a series that I did for
this thing we did call black geek week
at University Illinois used to teach at
University Illinois for eight years i
was there i was contacted by the the
black house that's the the cultural
studies Center for African American
Studies and they want to do this week
long celebration of various types of
black nerd culture so we lifted black
engineers physicists comics everything
and just kind of the celebration and
either some of the series that I did for
that becomes a black comics so what
started me thinking about this was I was
working on a show that was a response to
the Masters of American comic show which
was in 2005 out of the hammer museum out
west 15 of the greatest cartoonists to
ever touch a quill pen no women in the
show I was like okay so you can't be a
master okay so these are the masters of
married comics but you know Wendy penes
not in the show or or other female
artist known or familiar ours in the
show so anyway um there were also know
people call it in a show and also it
talked about a particular type of type
of comic that was being talked about in
that show as far as like from articulate
era a lot of people i really love like
Jack Kirby who was a huge influence of
mine Walt Kelly you know Joe Simon
people like that but not not the the
brothers Fernandez for instance when I
don't know for love and rockets yeah I
even Scott McCloud those whose I want to
become as theorists rights okay what
would criteria for this you know I don't
get it Chris where I was in there but
again those particular artists were
responding to a particular subset of a
type of comic book now I did kind of
misrepresent the
that there weren't any people of color
in the show there was George Herman who
was actually passing for white actually
he's actually if I was Greek but he'd
used to crazy cat back in the day it's
like 1928 he's the crazy cat so other
than that you know so me my friend
Damian started working on a show called
out of sequence which I don't have
images from because I don't want to go
into it too much but we were looking at
diversity writ large like not only who
was making the comics how they were
being produced you know gallery comics
webcomics basically the idea to
persistence a particular type of
mediation you know that that's what we
were really interested in so instead of
15 artists we had like over 60 artists
214 pieces and it was at the University
Illinois and was probably wanted I
thought was one the most innovative
comic shows ever but it happened in the
cornfield I know if he'd been a
university Illinois but it was all other
young each cook if it's on either coast
i think it probably a bigger show in a
bigger show so what starts to happen is
once we like realize that we went to
this show we realized we had never
curated a show before so we did a
practice show at Jackson State call
other heroes and it was supposed to be a
small show the kind of like practice
curation end up being 148 pieces like
over 20 or so artists it was nuts but it
was all african-american artists and
talking about stereotypes in comics this
particular book kind of came out of that
discussion you know we didn't want to
get wise black comic book artists but
what we started happening was we were
looking at this culture that was kind of
simmering since the 1990s like early 90s
a lot of people call the black Age of
comics and and so the gentleman a coined
that particular term was turtle on Lee
who was a black combo publisher himself
and distributor it's kinda like the
master p a-- comics but he would do is
get content by black creators and
literally like drive them around from
space to space and sell them out of the
back of his car right so he was like
i've heard about the Golden Age comics
heard about the Silver Age of comics
Bronze Age comics what about the black
age and so before you know it you have
these independent black spaces that are
selling independent comic books you know
and that's what this is a collection of
right it's out of print unfortunately so
the other thing is um I love
collaborating right so I've do a lot of
collaborative
works I love work with movers like
dancers and choreographers I love making
work about translations between movement
and other types of visual culture so
this is Cynthia Oliver she is a teacher
of dance at University Illinois and we
were having a dinner and / wine we're
talking about the differences or the
connections between comics and dance you
know I didn't realize at first that they
don't have like dance classes they have
composition classes realize that they
actually have composition classes
choreography literally means dance
writing right so I like this idea of the
body as a dancer as a mark making
instrument right so that's that's a
graphic design to right there so how do
we deal with that particular space so
this was called a closure for blood
gutter so veins I think I don't know how
many glasses of why we're in 24 we came
up with this but it was like about a
15-minute presentation her student
dancers it was the first time I did this
guy stuffs I had to beat it every
curtain call I had I designed you know
costumes I did like a lot of the scenery
that kind of thing and this was a few
years ago but I love working with I love
working with Cynthia but also loved
working with dancers in general so we're
working on a new piece called Veera go
for a space in Vermont that deals with
Jamaican masculinity politics and visual
culture she loved Jamaican descent so a
lot of her movement vocabulary art is
from the afro-caribbean space and just
sees the stills just from the
performance which I kind of love as
stills yeah that brings us to Junkanoo
this is a project that I worked on with
a key to carry and Deborah deadly again
I was thinking about this idea of
translation of choreography as a writing
instrument so I know you guys it is all
the time we put like mapping things over
people's bodies probably cost like a
gajillion dollars right goo Gillian
simoleons yeah right alright so this
costs like tinder ten bucks i went to
like the dollar store and i took these
lights put them all over her body and
filmed over at low shutter speed which
should probably familiar with right
so by themselves are really interesting
compositions all right you can actually
start to see some of the calligraphic
motion is happening right now i'll keep
the carry created her own dance
vocabulary called carob funk when she
took like afro-caribbean move it
vocabularies infused it with modern
dance so he's trying to figure out ways
to codify that and kind of disperse it
right and solace let's do some
experiments with different ways of like
translating it can in to enter into
other forms right so what I did is I
sampled snippets from these these
motions when these light forms and just
created typeface called yukia and I base
some of this stuff off of the Caribbean
of the gym skinny bohemian carnival
space which is called Junkanoo which is
what we got the title of the project
from as I started doing some experiments
with these type of graphic forms i wanta
do some more with these but you know
these are just some experiments we did
based off of the translation of like
this objectified like female body into
like it's really symbolic kind of
symbolic language that brings us the
black kirby which is probably what one
of the most extensive like ongoing
collaborative projects that i've worked
on so I was talking to Stacy Robinson
who's my collaborated with black Kirby
and this is around of time that any
comics comics comic scholars in the
audience right there are some people
right you remember the lawsuit that was
going on between Jack Kirby's family and
and Disney as far as like remuneration
for his Forza for his creations for
Marvel Comics in particular right this
is around the time the first Avengers
movie came out and made like a billion
dollars worldwide I'm like a billion
dollars right so I don't even know or
not but a lot of artists are still paid
in the comics industry page by page they
get a page rate and of course if you
working for like too big to DC and
Marvel then you're getting you know well
you're basically just you're working on
their characters you don't own those
characters right and so Jack Kirby even
though he was like one of the greatest
cartoon us to ever live and was really
like part of creating like you know an
entire universe we're talking the Silver
Surfer the fan
look for the x-men on a few familiar
with these at all right you know you
watch comic book movies okay thank you I
know what those are all right cool all
right so so he co-created all this stuff
right and family was like well I always
worked for higher but maybe you could
break us off some money you know that
would be nice no like no we're not going
to do that because we're Disney and
we're evil so when I gonna do that all
right so Stacy and I didn't think that
was right it was like you know what
that's not right they treating that
brother like he was black so black Kirby
was like hey there you go black Kirby so
then we started thinking about the
connections between some of the
metaphorical things that were talking
about in the x-men the fact that they
did create the first major black
superhero the Black Panther for months
before the Black Panthers call
themselves that by the way which I
thought was extremely interesting so a
lot of those particular types of
connections we just made more explicit
right there's this kind of thing about
like you know Malcolm X being like
magneto and you know Charles Xavier you
know being dr. King which is totally
that's probably not right but but it's
interesting though right it's
interesting you know and so they
actually created some really problematic
characters to like why is the black
racer the spirit of death black I don't
understand what first it's like why is
on skis it's the first day but then also
why is he this black character you know
death anyway so the conflation of death
and blackness is something that's like
historical right the other fact is that
we look at forever people does a
character call Viking the black and he
happens to be black character say oh ok
that's interesting as well so anyway so
we started thinking about like black
Kirby in this alternative universe where
he was informed by you know black power
politics because guess what in the 60s
that kind of stuff was jumping off right
maybe instead of being informed by you
know Norse mythology he was he was
informed by afro-caribbean mythology or
like West African mythology so so the
Mighty Thor becomes the mighty Shango
same same guy you know he has an ax
instead of a hammer but you know the
same same kind of character and then we
started thinking about constructions of
monstrosity around blackness so I said
Incredible Hulk
the unkillable buck right which is
actually extremely telling when you look
at like some of the descriptions of the
black body now but take me look at like
Darren Wilson's description of Michael
Brown when he's 20 is shooting him he
was a demon he was a monster right so
this idea of the golem from Jewish
mythology and how it again becomes an
idea around the grotesque right and how
these particular ideas start to kind of
play themselves out and Jack Kirby's
work had all kinds of golems and it
right like you have this thing you know
it's a go he was Jack Kirby you know it
was pretty much like this bulky rock guy
right that's Jack Kirby sorry saw
himself so anyway so these are remixes
of these particular types of ideas and
just kind of sampling or mixing Jack
Kirby's aesthetic but also adding our
own influences from afrofuturism from
hip hop from black power politics yes
the uncanny Kingsman you know it was
funny because Gosnell scot-free he's
this character called mister miracle
he's the ultimate escape artist I saw
this call Gil scot-free and my friend
was like you know what you should have a
jill scott free i think you know why
you're right and that's kind like how it
was it was like really interactive thing
this idea of like you know this black
character who ultimate escape our artist
was just I mean that's too good to pass
up getting killed by buck returns sorry
yeah so our process was this I mean
sometimes I would draw something to pass
it off to Stacey he would mess around
with it send it back to me there's a lot
of caller response involved and that
kind of thing so as far as like the
critical making aspect of it was really
fun so over a month and a half we made
120 images and they we've actually like
shown this you know worldwide actually
so and we're actually starting to talk
about stories so this is darkside
remixed as black hand side this
particular piece was I actually eight
feet tall it was a without the funky
totem series that kind of thing we also
did these abstract comics abstract
comics are basically like narratives
that are sequential in nature but
actually not objective so this was
influenced by DJ Spooky one of my
favorite
media theorists but also it's a good DJ
you know stuff and so this whole piece
was like inspired by some of his quotes
so it's like the only finish comic in
the whole serious about 36 pages right
which brings us a kid code what was
going to what was happening with the
black Kirby stuff is that we were making
these kind of prototypes of of magazines
that could have been or that would be or
might have been right people that will
so when's that black where's that a that
book book coming out I was like all
right peace it's a it's like pop art you
know was that major sankofa piece coming
up said no it's not a book it's actually
not a book no and then we started
thinking like okay well let's make some
original books so we started making
original content as black Kirby so kid
code is really influenced by my love for
time travel stories on the mass of
Doctor Who fan mahuva in trade out of
Gallifrey I love that stuff I love it I
grew up what read network I'm gonna see
me watch network and it just totally
influenced the way I look at like sci-fi
that's why I had this long scarf its
base to Tom Baker that's the only Doctor
Who sorry could fight about it later but
that's my doctor anyway so if you take
like Doctor Who and you mix it with like
green lantern and Africa and bada and
like r mlz a little bit there you go so
the stories like this I'm gonna break
down a storm pitcher to you at the
beginning of time there was the guy
Dempsey right got him see spoke the
world into existence he had his crew
carloads of light they hung out with
them some of them were haters so what
ends up happening is they sampled his
voice a simple God's voice and it remix
the entire universe and to what this
mess is the dark mix right so his other
homeboy father time created the Knights
of infinite diggings the kid is actually
a title Knights of the infinite digging
so basically they travel do this like
time quilt that's that's a constructed
by these four djs called unfaded before
the quitters called the incredible so he
jumps through these pieces and they're
trying to collect up the shards of God's
original voice to remix it to the
original format so it's almost like a
shout out to
sex chat with afrofuturism but also to
these notions of like old-school hip-hop
and there's a dozen anti-capitalist
narrative too because the main villain
the hater is called the power you know
so as you can see as the grill this is
cream which is cash rules everything
around me right and so they're trying to
stop the the power from remix in the
universe and then stop in the universe
using channel 0 because every time we
get close to stopping him he resets
everything so we have to find channel 0
stop that so since I just kind of Star
Wars narrative too so it's a big mixmash
of a like a lot of different things and
the aesthetic is pretty much based off
of similar stuff we were like really
into like Jack Kirby's work but also
like graffiti you know the idea like the
formal notions of graffiti so it's like
all the way plays and our first book is
like 40 pages long people like oh my god
it's like dollar 99 off like 40 pages
we're gonna do next with this so right
now we're working on the second part you
know and it's published by rose Aryan
publishing which is one of the most
progressive publishers of like science
fiction and fantasy right now they do
like comics but they also do original
prose work very diverse writers they're
you know from various backgrounds well I
love about they have like a kind of
women's initiative they want to actually
publish more women who are writing you
know science fiction and fantasy so it's
a great great company owned by Bill
Campbell I need of some of the spreads
from kid coat brings us a night boy so I
don't have even watching the news but it
seems that there's been a lot of police
brutality against the black body in
major cities right so this particular
character is in response to that
characters real name is Jamal jemison
from Chicago really big comics fan
himself artist been sketching this image
of himself actually humanists in his
cousin are coming out of a comic book
store and they get into it with a cop
cousin is killed Jamal is injured while
he's convalescing in the hospital he's
visited by these two nite spirits and
given this mantle of the basic like the
Paladin of the dark his powers come from
deferred dreams so and he also is a
shadow bender so you can actually take
shadows bend
to his will but basically all the
potential energy of his cousin's life
cut short his father's dreams his
grandfather's dreams he can actually
call upon those particular powers they
actually ate him there's a shadow shadow
shifter but really what he is like kind
of a gargoyle character so he guards us
from these night spirits that's another
product we're working on right now it's
going to be a hybridized to form so it's
gonna be like graphic novels but also
pros as well well love about is that a
lot of us going to be about the family
you know so that's his little sister
who's a brilliant bring a girl who
discovers that he actually is night boy
he said can ask about we could talk
about it another thing I was really
proud of was artists against police
brutality which is the comics anthology
my friend Bill Campbell called me after
the Eric garner non-decision and was
irate what we have out of a nap I don't
get a lot of those and he was he want to
do something about it so basically what
we started working on was a collection
of stories about police brutality from
comics but also analysis from like
scholars and all the proceeds are going
to his the Innocence Project so that's
the current project just up right now as
well 61 artists and participants gives
me like in scholars and again this is
from rosarium publishing which he named
after his daughter by the way his
daughter's name is rose so that's kind
of cool this one my favorite and most
painful pieces it's about Barbara
Brendan Croft and I don't know if you
can see the daytonas but she's talking
about police brutality but the date is
like 2000 right it almost didn't make
that it almost did make the volume until
I showed it to Jason Rodriguez and I was
like dude look at the date on this it's
like 16 years ago right still the same
problem still the same issues still the
same assassination at a black body and
so we were dealing with this with the
comics piece which I love about the fact
that comics are so irreverent and they
can deal with these types of issues I'm
sorry about harping about it was what I
study for obvious reasons it's part of
what I do so I was like looking at a
construction and a destruction at a
black by
AV Jeter stuff is so good look at that
she has it actually does like a zombie
comic book is called nothing good
happens at 3am in the morning or nothing
good is suck anyway there's a portrait
this kind of become like the about
Ashley woods and she did like these
caricatures of some of the victims like
the most famous victims you know what's
really interesting about this book
though is by and just came out and since
tarragona answered it up to the
publication which I think it's where I
met Sasha doing mice right over almost
900 people have died since dead at the
hands of police brutality so and those
people are listed in the back so again
I've been doing a lot of afrofuturism
covers for some reason I kind of
stumbled into helping to shape the
aesthetic of like what's been looked at
as afrofuturism these days so these are
some of the covers Octavia's boot is
really interesting because it starts to
deal with the idea of how these various
like grass roots black political
movement start to intersect with black
speck of culture right and so I've been
thinking about this notion what I call
the blacks pickled of Arts Movement and
how it kind of parallels some of the
things that were happening in the Black
Arts Movement which was the sister to
the Black Power movement right and so me
and my friend Ronaldo anderson who is
editing this two-volume piece from
lexington books with charles jones he's
calling it afrofuturism two point oh so
he's looking at afrofuturism and black
scale of culture through various lenses
so we have someone writing about
religion from performative culture from
you know from aesthetics from aesthetics
various types of writing and
epistemology is looking at this culture
is looking through this culture as a
lens so and so we put together manifesto
that we're kind of passing around right
now he also is the co-curator of the
unveiling vision show which I talk about
in a second but this is again from
rosarian publishing their this is the
first book they actually got from some
notoriety dealing with black speck of
culture and black speckles writings from
various standpoints yes it is anthology
as it stated earlier one of the things
that I've been interested in
is building community spaces I'm really
into Theaster gates right now I think I
mentioned some other people earlier but
his process is building community has
MFA in like studio art he's a Potter and
he's in Chicago and what he's been doing
is using his money from making art to
buy old dilapidated buildings in Chicago
and revamping interment community art
spaces what I've been doing recently is
thinking about creating these kind of
think tanks and spaces where
collaborative energy can be shared well
both creatively politically around black
expected of cultures so astro blackness
was something I found it at Loyola
Marymount with oddly foo nama who wrote
a book called black space he's a film
studies professor and also he did his
book called super black which is about
which is about black superheroes
actually too and so we started working
out how to go about this kind of like
colloquium and we've done it for two
years and we have a spin-off I might
talk about that in a second we're going
to do a third one next year and it's in
LA and some of the top like scholars and
creators in this genre come and talk
about this work in that space not a lil
hop kristen calls it the black sci-fi
church because it's kind of like what it
is the other thing has been happening is
that this black underground independent
comics culture has cons there's a
convention circuit actually the Lord
oldest one is in Philly is called East
Coast black Age of comics conventions
they're on for 14 years all right you
ever seen it never heard of it no maybe
yeah it start it's there though right
it's right in front of you there's also
kids comic con created by alex simmons
there is one called mecha kindness in
detroit there's another in detroit
called the Motor City black Age of
comics this morning Atlanta has been off
for eight years called onyx con there's
a system of these particular conventions
and I've added a couple more so a few
years ago we founded the black combat
festival at the schaumburg where me
Jonathan gales Deirdre Holman who works
there and also Jerry craft who's been
doing black black comic book day at
human book fest look our store which is
now on for
defunct founded the black carnival
festival at the Schomburg Center first
one brought in about 1200 people when it
was wild it was like the schaumburg was
not ready for that everything I know if
you've been to that space but they were
not ready for that kind of geekery to
jump off at a library that I we're
talking about a space where Langston
Hughes is ashes are buried in the and
the foundation right and comic book
geeks in like what is going on so yeah
so yeah it was pretty wild so then we've
done a couple more this was the fourth
annual I'll show you some pictures from
that and I was like okay well let's see
if we can do something on the west coast
so i was working i do a seminar with the
MFA program on comics in calif excuse me
in san francisco and when my best
friend's is married to aaron guzel names
Colette and he is the CEO of the MLK
norcal which is like the MLK foundation
of San Francisco and it's pretty big
actually they do a massive MLK festival
there we're talking like 30 40 thousand
people come out and do a march and end
up at the year between the Art Center
and they split off in a different
festivals so the black comic arts
festival is the 12th festival that
they've doing so that he's over all
these festivals simultaneously potential
one person you know enterprise it's
pretty wild so our first one brought in
about 1600 people you know so what I did
was I do this one in New York in Harlem
I jump on a plane in the middle of that
one I fly out west's and so I do both on
MLK weekend and then I pass out later
because this is pretty wild this year
these are the posters from this year so
at the schaumburg we had about 6,000
people Maya was there actually wasn't
complaining about about the amount of
people yeah and I want that to happen
because here's the thing one of the one
of the misnomers about like black folk
is that we don't like science fiction we
don't like fantasy we don't like comic
books we don't like any stuff and I'm
like no I was born and raised on this
stuff this is what this is what my
culture is and so you had this massive
turnout I told the Dean earlier was like
that new iPad what iphone was dropping
or something people queued up right you
know trying to get up in there
you know to buy independent black comic
books you know it was out of control and
we had pieces about afrofuturism we had
think we had a pound by publishing we
had a whole panel about black geek
culture and the fact that is being so
now it's a new journalistic enterprise
you have all these podcasts and
magazines and everything that's covering
this you know and it's funny though
because when I've been interviewed by
major news sources about diversity and
comics right and they want me to talk
about Black Panther and Falcon being
captain america and all this kind of
stuff but I always mentioned this
culture and they never they never
published me talking about his culture
right I'm talk to this woman after
American reporter from CBS for two hours
two hours about this acid sister that's
what I said as a sister sister I know
you're not connected me to use this
because it's not talking about the
mainstream but if you really want to see
diversity a representation of us come to
this space I saw to Marvel editors at
this day yeah it was pretty interesting
and they were like it is going home
right because David Walker was there who
was writing like you know [ __ ] he was
writing shaft is right like cyborg and
other things right these are some of the
people there you know just kind of
showing off the shirts here's my
publisher that's Bill Campbell as Jason
Rodriguez this is a the rosarium table
some of the where's their have black
panther outside with the q see in the
middle of harlow this this particular
line was wrapped around a bill in a
couple of times that's David Walker who
is an avid like independent critics
collar of like of various types of media
actually particularly film and filmmaker
too but he's writing like Power Man and
Iron Fist he just stopped writing cyborg
he wrote the shaft comic book based off
the novels and he's getting ready to
write Nighthawk for Marvel and he sold
out by like three o'clock he was sold
out someone gave him a book and put it
on his table someone tried to buy the
book that someone gave him it's like
because that that's how much that
particular crowd has been ignored you
know and so these particular spaces are
feeding that hunger the other thing I
did
was i co-founded soul kind which is the
first black and Latino Convention which
is at Ohio State University Columbus
Ohio is a big comics town that's where
the cartoon research library is the
Billy Ireland so this was the first time
that this is jumped off as a black and
Latino independent card the next one's
gonna be october fourteenth numbers
weren't as good just make for different
reasons but i think that by moving it to
the library it's going to be it's gonna
be a lot better so it's always been
great it's already been greenlit yeah it
was it was a great time so unveiling
visions was a show that took off
teaching to do at the schaumburg and it
was looking at the material culture and
the ephemera around producing a black
speck of culture so like book cover
design poster designs the other thing
we're doing is like diegetic prototypes
of things that were talked about in
speculative fiction written by black
people like for instance i mentioned it
earlier like George Tyler's black no
more chair the chair for my black no
more the the story that could turn black
people in the white people but not quite
you know so what does that chair look
like or the pig detector from from amiri
baraka story called the pig detector and
so what does that look like you know or
the afro horn from Henry Dumas is peace
or even more recently the mega scope
from this sci-fi story that WB the boys
wrote in 1908 did it just discover so
object so what do those objects look
like you put those into this show using
the trope of the data thief right my
data thief was a construct because it's
construct that came from this
documentary came out in the late 1990s
by John account for they looked at black
digital music right it was called the
last angel of history data thief was
pretty much a time-traveling
archaeologist he was a huge pleasure was
a huge influence on kid code actually to
write so uh losing people suz asleep
sorry anyway yeah thanks
I know after that day you go um anyone
I've had coffee so I'm like I'm good
thank you well it's interesting though
that we were utilizing the technology so
all this stuff is like reprints of
things right so we're utilizing this the
space as an archive so what is what
happens when someone who's an
archaeologist becomes like a curator a
time-traveling curator right starts
pulling from all these different spaces
and we're able to put up this really
kind of robust show about 10,000 people
visited it in the shop at the schaumburg
it's a really fun show and it's probably
going to travel now which I'm excited
about right now we're finishing up the
publication but 15 really strong essays
for that for the piece how to finish my
intro and working so yeah what we did is
like we divided up all of the these
spaces the black fantastic that would
like black fantasy but a space called
Dark Matters to dealt with this
construction that I called the
ethnographic we had things deal with
like music and technology you know that
kind of thing so we try to look at all
the different types of material cultures
and how they informed you know black
cultural production in this space I love
the fact that you can see the archive
and you can counter see Aaron Douglases
work i love the fact that you can see
the past and the future some and a
present simultaneously innocent a cipher
itself right and there's summat layout
now i have to thought I have to think
like I sister come out of John who's a
new director of galleries there because
I wanted to be like a street seed I
wanted to be like opulent everything
that you see I wanted I wanted to be
three times bigger you know I wanted
people walking in like oh my god you
know she would not allow me to do that
but that's cool you know sweet he worked
out immediately diem right so one of the
things that's another thing I took off
time to do is work on the adaptation of
Octavia Butler's kindred I won't go into
how I stumbled into that project but I'm
extremely grateful also like oh my god
what am i doing and because it's 240
page full color book right now I'm in
the middle of doing the breakdowns for
the pages and one big thing is that the
the estate for Octavia Butler has
already signed off on the book so that
was a big deal you know so because if
they didn't like it it was a no-go and I
just hours and I would cry
right into my computer but they liked it
so do some of the early character
sketches for kindred so the main
characters and i'm going to show you
pages from it like only this state and
some other people have actually seen
pages from it but that's Rufus and Alice
and other these are early early sketches
that's what the covers go look like it's
a prologue you guys know the story ok
they're about so here's some of the
early images / can't wait to be done
with this project I'm excited about it
it's a lot of damn work though cuz now
that once i finish the breakdowns to go
back and draw everything over again in
color I'm telling all the artwork for it
so it's a labor of love but it's a lot
of work but it's going to be cool
because it's going to be split come out
next year a hardcover really nice
printing I was going to be marketed
internationally it's going to be the big
deal is probably in town for us it would
have been a 70th birthday actually so
that's gonna be really cool alright so
as a space I think afrofuturism has been
used as kind of a catch-all for
everything black and speculative which I
don't think is necessarily the case like
kindred for instance Octavia Butler
herself calls it a dark fantasy she
actually frames it that way it's not
like people know how the time-travel
happens all she knows she's popping from
one time from one times on to the other
there's not a TARDIS you know a time
machine is active right she's shifting
because of this connection to a
traumatic space right and so the other
narratives like that to wear this kind
of time travel is happening you know
mystically right so I started thinking
about other ways of thinking about black
the black speculative and a lot of it
came from looking at comics like cloak
and dagger right where are you very
problematic comics from 90s to deal with
like both racially and gender politics
is very problematic but you know the
blackmail is a open space he's basically
a disembodied cloak that eats you you
know which is actually one of my
influences for the whole actually
but it's a very gothic space right and
gothic and a weighted we talking about
like ideas around other around the
grotesque around the monstrous
fictitious histories those types of
tropes of the gothic and how like the
gothic as a space relate to black
experiences in America in general you
know or could be associated with those
particular active spaces so stories like
handyman which really is like a
anti-miscegenation narrative right
ternana reeve dues work who is the black
female stephen king that's what she is
tales from the hood sugarhill the
character from Taylor what was the died
oh my god wasn't it with trilogy of
terror with a little do need all this
chasing down cat you remember yes she's
like yeah all those characters they're
problematic but they're dealing with
these really shadowed spaces that aren't
really talking about science fiction and
fantasy in the way that we're thinking
about the future right but for some
reason they'll take like sunrise music
and shove it under afrofuturism when I
think it probably fits there but you
know space is like like daughters of the
dust for instance I think by Julie dash
that to me is a gothic narrative like
you have the present and the future and
the past coexisting and the future looks
like haunting the president it's like
wonderful movie but it's kind of it
freaks you out you know and so a lot of
deals with like these like spiritual
spaces that don't think science fiction
really really deals with I like this
idea of like the ghost as a reified
agent of trauma right and how do you
deal with that beloved for instance by
Toni Morrison that's a scary story
that's a ghost story the arc of bones by
Henry Dumas that's a ghost story you
know dealing with like this idea of like
the transatlantic slave enterprise and
how that informs you know race in
America right so that's what these
particular pieces are this is actually
from a five-part visual essay I did for
like obsidian magazine about what I term
is death no gothic right but it'd be
kind of like obsessed with so so most of
the projects that I'm doing right now
are taking us back in Mississippi so
this particular character his name is
Frank half dead Johnson he's the
fictitious cousin of Robert Johnson the
blues man
what happens is due to a racialized
violence issues owed his family is
killed and so instead of wanting to be a
virtual of virtuoso at the blues guitar
he wants revenge which makes perfect
sense well it's justice he wants revenge
he wants to be at peace in some fashion
so instead of a instead of like getting
you know his virtuosity with it with
instrument he wants to become a very
powerful conjurer so that he can
actually exact revenge against the
people that killed his family and that's
what he does and then what happens is he
immediately regrets his decision figures
out a way to like trick the devil and to
like let them out of his uh his
agreement a little bit he actually beats
the doublet craps that seems like the
devil can only throw sixes so he tricks
him and he moves to chicago you know and
to ply his trade the devil's like hey
you know what i like like you me i won't
give you half of your soul back dustin
in half dead and you have to work for me
for like a couple hundred years on this
blues song I'm working on soon as that
souls resonate in a particular tonality
and he's composing a blues song for
rapture so to a certain degree Frank is
actually tracking down these souls for
this this blues song it's called the
lowdown devil blues that he's trying to
compose for the end of the world and so
this is the story I'm working that's
blue hand mojo and it was really
interesting to me back up a couple oh
I'm going to wrong way it sorry ah
benwar was based off of my Monica
ressies work she does his beautiful
pieces about you know the black figures
but basically she's like a living like
spirit tree but the gnar is in love with
Frank that's where all those powers come
from and so the idea is that his hand
which he like witches in her to pull his
power out the more uses power the more
it creeps up over his body and so what
happens is if he doesn't drink this
elixir he will actually become just a
story and he has to live in Anwar
forever you know with her so he's always
trying to fight against that particular
piece as well but this is where all
black creativity comes from it's called
the noir as a construction the spirit
tree is of course are informed by like
who do practices like catching evil
spirits and things of that nature
and of course he's coupled with a quilt
and to backtrack my mother and my
grandmother of quilters so I actually
keep seeing like the quilt popping up in
my work this teal color hain't blue
Gavin what i hain't is for ghost height
hot you know but it's like that's what
we call them down south haints so the
story is like this when you see those
houses down south painted with that
color they're tricking the spirits to go
into the into that because they think
that it's the sky you know and so now
it's becoming oh hey blue but no
actually it's like we're trying to
protect the house when I was growing up
most of the houses that we lived in
haripur painted that color and also had
like bridles and like horseshoes right
because horses would suppose be the ward
off evil spirits right and would stop
haints from getting into the space right
it's interesting i love that kind of
stuff like for like focal oh but i keep
seeing how it like permeates allow the
work that i'm working on right now limit
the box of bones as a project I'm
working on right now too it's probably
like the largest collaborative project
that ever worked on whenever I do my
elevator pitch i call it like
afrocentric Hellraiser the Hellraiser
okay like yeah I don't think okay so um
so basically it goes like this there's
this um there's this black woman who is
a visual culture researcher at Berkeley
this is the character name is Lindsey
forward she's studying folklore and she
comes across this box that's described
in various loads of a research and I
throughout the Diaspora that it's a box
of revenge or as a box of pain something
called the shadow box something called
the black box but most people call it
the box of bones so the stories go
throughout the Diaspora that if
something happens to you or your loved
one your need for revenge or anger cause
the box to you and there are six spirits
that live in the box and the right one
will possess you your executor revenge
and you owe it something sanity body
part you'll love one maybe I live in the
box a little bit so it actually kind of
plays around with the idea of like the
differences between like morality and
justice and all these different types of
like really tense story notions right so
all these characters are based off of
traditional like black stereotypes likes
a black brute that characters called the
oh my god forgot the name the character
I love a second it's not to burden the
suffering that's his name the suffering
that's the dark that's nobody as a new
body news the dribble hace right and
that's the burden which is pretty much
like a cotton sack filled with like
Slade body parts and it's always
replenishing them so it kind of creeps
around I wanted to make things I'd like
would treat me out which is hard because
I watch a lot of horror movies so the
other thing is like I want to design
characters that if I'd room and shadows
you can see which one will company was
coming to get you right i'm working with
six different artists and working with a
years age of my Everett who is like
up-and-coming science fiction fantasy
writer out of the bay area it's called
box of bones we're working on right now
probably kick-started taken to a
publisher he thinks that we could
probably getting published by like image
comics or something was like image is
not gonna publish that damn thing no
one's gonna publish that we have to
polish it ourselves right publish a book
about black rage in a box i don't think
so i don't think so can do a falcon book
not not this though the night doctor the
night doctor is based off the plague
doctors right it's about medical
apartheid about the experimentations
done still being done to a certain
degree on black bodies through our
history that's what that character
represents these some of the pages I'm
going to probably revisit some of this
stuff though to deads it blames us to
almost in planet deep south is a
offshoot of the black ops capable of
astro blackness I like this idea of like
the south is kind of like this hard at
space or like a reclaiming like the
black imaginary space allow these people
who are dealing with afrofuturism as a
cultural production space are from the
south like Sunhwa Harry Dumas Zora Neale
Hurston blowfly you know all those all
those phouka from the south you know I
like this idea of how using this
particular type of ideology like dr.
King becomes afrofuturism Fanta Lou
Hamer becomes afro futurist or you know
Medgar Evers becomes a futurist because
it's about aspiring to get out of a
particular
base to escape you know and so if you
look at light could the work of like
outcasts Janelle Monae or net Coleman
and redo my who I think it's like the I
would say he's like the patron saint of
this idea of the black speck of Arts
Movement because most of his work was
was published posthumously by his best
friend Eugene Redmond and it was also a
coke he also was helped by Toni Morrison
he's a huge influence on Toni Morrison
he died really early he was in Harlem
coming from a Sun rock concert and he
was killed by a cop through mistaken
identity so you see how like these
particular things have been happening
for a while and intersecting with you
know black speck of culture which i
think is kind of scary this is David
Banner who's become like an afro
futurist kind of social justice agent
was a rapper you know and and that leads
us to the cyber travel in with the cyber
trap so I was actually invited by Henry
Jenkins of the folk to go and talk about
the legacies of cyberpunk and I'll of
cyberpunk as a space but I was like well
how does my work or how other people
work who's working in space relate to
cyberpunk and he was looking at the
black Kirby kind of work as relating to
it I was thinking about these notions of
like the trap of the cyber trap trap
music basically is a really grungy drug
infested culture it deals the music it's
a music genre this part of hip-hop
culture and the early stuff is like ti
UGK those particular rappers early
outcasts deals with like this drug
culture like today's trap music is very
light to comparison to a lot of the
early stuff like feel mob goodie mob
those particular those particular
rappers so what happens when you infuse
that with cyberpunk culture so this is a
world that I'm building right now that
with my friend Regina Bradley my friend
Tim fielder there's a future space that
has been such a dystopian black urban
space that deals with like techno drugs
and different things of that nature but
really what it is is a way to look at or
to kind of telegraph some things that
are happening in
of particular black South because it
seems like people are really paying
attention outside of like the music
culture and other things that are
happening right and it still
romanticized to a sex or a certain
degree so my friend Wilton Davis just
put out this book called cyberpunk which
is like black cyberpunk so I would look
at that like this idea has been like a
sub-genre of that particular like kind
of construction so say all that to say
is that I've been doing this work trying
to escape Mississippi until like a until
like a virtual space to try to get the
hell out of there and I ended up back
there so it brings us to here and we'll
stop talking and you can reel me with
questions thank you for attention hope I
was riveting all right all right thank
you for bearing with me it's a lot of
like stories sorry and it's hot up here
all right so what we're going to do is
just cute name for a while and then I'll
wrap it up by six thirty and then I need
to meet with your grad students about
their food situation okay
I what kind of questions comments river
marks or interact thanks thanks very
much I wanted to ask I guess about some
about collaboration which you talked
about you're doing a different projects
also there's definitely this current of
discussion of you know some of the
differences between industrial
production comics mmm Disney and in
paper page and and also the way that
task r / role mm-hmm you know and that's
quite different from selling comics out
the back of a truck marry my son and
people who are taking a role throughout
the whole process and so I guess my
question is how did how does how does
your practice has collaboration work for
you and how do you help students to
engage in these more productive maybe
less industrialized types of ways okay
you're right i mean i was talking with
speaking about this earlier where the
big to Marvel and DC aren't really comic
book companies really they're more like
IP farms you know and it just happened
to be a leg of these huge multinational
companies one of the things that i think
a lot of independent comics wait you
know what let me let me be more specific
i'll take a lot of the the people were
african-american who are making comics
suffer from this notion of nostalgia as
far as like they remember going to the
stop and go and get in the comic books
every month you know that kind of thing
and so they're thinking that that's the
count thing that they want to do I want
to put out this book every month not
realizing that okay you know what
there's a team of people making those
books there's a huge machine is pushing
those books out you know aren't on a
consistent basis and there's a lot of
work that goes into that right and it's
a lot of mastery of particular skill
sets as you were saying thinkers writers
that kind of thing along a while ago I
kind of let go this idea of the loan art
or working in the studio I am a genius
and I shall make this thing right you
know and the students I stick I think
petilla undergrad students are still
thinking about that notion you know so
I'm so what I try to do is foster
collaboration as much as possible
breaking them up into groups forcing
them to work with each other you know
that kind of thing in various in various
types
faces and to show what's what I'm doing
with these types of collaborative
efforts because to me the story's got to
get out it's all about the story and so
I don't care if I have to share the IP
if I have to do colors on a project like
with the [ __ ] a box of bones project I
drew one chapter of it but i'm not
drawing the rest of it you know I'm
actually just doing the colors and in my
friend Dana's doing inking and I
basically have coerced you know
successfully six other artists to like
invest their time in this and try to
make something happen with it the
economics of it are just staggering
though because there's this characters
his comic book called called brother man
that actually was was created in the
1990s and you can read about it here a
whole family The Sims family they
created this character that was supposed
to like advertiser airbrush an airbrush
business right turns out that the comic
books were actually more profitable than
airbrush business they sold by hand
750,000 copies of that book they had I
know right that 1111 issues of it then
what happened is like the mother and the
father of that was our parents died back
to back and totally shut down the entire
piece so that would add his highlight
that was the devil's that was the
epitome of like collaboration right
because the parents were hand like some
of the business the brother was doing
writing that was drawing it and let's c
and s obviously guys sales was writing
it so so you could see like so that that
cooperative economics happening there
right i try to foster those faces
through those are those comic-book
conventions and do some of the the astro
blackness work where people are sitting
down with the people that are studying
and coming up with different ways to
attack those issues i think yeah I think
I think it probably is a fool's errand
to to try to make comic books on an
updated or not on a monthly basis like
that i'm thinking probably smaller
pieces like band ez'n a like like 48
page one shot pieces or like
proof-of-concept pieces or 60 page books
and put them out like the French do it
keep your costs low you know and do
black and white books when you can you
know which one reasons why i like doing
horrible cuz it lends itself to it
that's another reason
and do graphic novels and do anthologies
and that kind of thing where you can
work with other people to put the stuff
out you know and keep the quality up and
and get this get into those spaces where
people can get the product because
obviously there's a need for it but
they're not seeing it into the direct
market so the other thing is that the
direct market is a monopoly right which
is owned by diamond distribution right
so they have a stranglehold on a direct
market that's how people buy comic books
and it's very difficult to get into that
space very difficult so I dad did it
help okay yes sir just the pursuit of
the collaboration idea is this something
that they seems to work well with this
particular medium is that in Jordan
service meeting I mean a lot of the AR
necessarily collaborative that cost
active you are controllable or is it
something we mentioned in natural
futures lucky [ __ ] bunch of folks who
are sort of craters in that space is
over temperature yourself is this coming
from another
you know maybe wait that's that's right
that's a great question i am i've been
talking about this earlier we talked
about this the cosmic chitlin circuit
idea earlier right like the chitlin
circuit was a way that black musicians
just you know distributed their wares
right so they would travel to mostly
black spaces and it would play a juke
joints what have you and even hip-hop
started that way they actually would
because was just race music right at
first before it broke wide so what I've
been trying to do is what you're saying
is that create a network of these
alternative cons that actually become a
space where people who are producing
this type of consumable story can
actually make money doing this right and
so that's just part of it I think as far
as like the medium and affordances of
the medium i think that comics
definitely are can be a collaborative
medium but i think that also is because
of had have been traditionally done to
if you look at like a lot of really
successful independent people like Dave
sim for instance he was doing aardvark
Cerebus artwork and we did everything
himself you know that kind of pretty
much I think you know so a lot of times
you see those independent comics that
are control controlled by one lone
person but you do see some really
interesting collaborative things
sometimes in like the the lower tier
like independent comics like I look at
like what's his name ed brubaker and
Shaun Phillips they have like a they
have some really great collaborative
endeavors like fatale and like I
incognito and a few other things that
they've worked on together but they just
really work off of each other I think I
think the I think the notion is to be
open to sharing your ideas and not
necessarily being as you know as
capitalist minded you know because i
really i don't care about duquette my
money is awesome i guess you know in
this company but it's like it's not it's
not the end-all be-all to me I really
want to see the stories happen and I
think if you could find people like that
if you're lucky enough to find people
like that and that you can work with and
you're not like overly a territorial
that you can actually in comics do some
really amazing things with it you know
with the medium
such yeah an amazing talk thank you oh
thank you so it can be brown and melody
russia co-authors in my camp is fruit
mhm is amazing I know yeah you know part
of their proposal and not going to be
this brood is to say you know to think
about how science fiction is essential
to community organizing mm-hmm that is
one of social movements yep because it
allows us to envision the possible
alternative futures that we want to
build right here at MIT there's a lot of
energy around building technologies and
flexible futures but a lot of them are
stuck in a techno tophian unmarked and
therefore normative straight white well
female mmm majan airy mm-hmm I'm
wondering how you imagined your own like
practice and pedagogy how how does it
connect with with enough designers and
engineers and makers and builders and
the kind of critical design theory and
practically right you have what would it
what's that look like programmatically
like hi I'm trying to figure it out a
little bit because honest ones we talked
about earlier as far as like the
intersections between various modes of
study been thinking about like race as a
construction right maybe even race as a
diuretic prototype that was really
successful you know I'm saying that kind
of idea cuz it keeps popping up and in
but also intersecting with like various
types of legibility issues you know so
I'm thinking about what I've been
putting out there is like critical race
design studies you know which I didn't
necessarily put in the talk but it's
something they've kind of like thinking
about the black body is a type of text
various types of like design thinking
that engages with critical race theory
like traditional critical race theory
because we think about it Derek bells
work actually started out in speculative
work he's one of the forefathers of
critical race Theory right but he was
using were you talking about these these
these story prompts as ways to talk
about alternative ways of thing about
law right because critical race Theory
comes out of the law profession right
Terry Bell was a I think was at Harvard
right when he in Harvard I think he was
yeah as I recall and so you know ever
seen space traders
space traders is this story that he made
up to talk about property and race
actually so what happens in space
traders is like a sin to 80s these
aliens come down right and say hey we
will fix everything on your planet will
give you a bajillion dollars as that's a
lot of money also we will clean up the
entire world right we'll fix every
problem that you have systemically if
you give us all your population with a
certain amount of melanin content right
so so they have to vote even though they
had to vote there was actually like it's
interesting because HBO did this thing
called cosmic slop which is based off of
the you know the the Parliament
Funkadelic song right where they made
this into a series of coke it wasn't a
series of suppose because he was a pilot
by the headland brothers where they
actually did it was almost like a afro
futurist like twilight zone right you
can actually find pieces of this out on
the air on the web but that space trader
story is what I'm talking about like
where you use narrative and critical
thinking about race and then overlap
that into these like you know these kind
of fictional spaces how do you how do
what does that look like you know so
here so I'm I'm still working out if
this thing is going to be like a class
especially type of course or is it a new
way of thinking about design and
critical race theory I don't know yet
you know some still I'm still thinking
about it but I know that's gonna
probably have a huge critical making
component and like two huge but design
history probably in media studies
various modes of thinking to kind of
like come together and form this kind of
idea around how to talk about those
things because you're right issues like
the cyber trap for instance that could
really happen I mean the cyber trap
could actually happen you know down
south it really could so how do you map
those types of like racialized spaces
because of very racialized space with
science fiction and fantasy you know and
create worlds like that so I'm I'm still
working through it but i think that uh i
don't know i think i want to write sure
i'm looking for to devote it sometime to
it that's for sure so it's a half answer
looks like yes sir in yeah there are you
doing this is
okay hey so I think it's really amazing
all the stuff you do the drawing the
Arctic Eurasian community building is is
there a analytical component to your
work as well yeah oh yeah oh yeah
definitely actually um I have a book out
right now that i did a co-edited piece
called a black of the ink that actually
just won a book award like a pca ACA for
best edited collection so I do like some
analysis as well there's this really
cool collection called what is the
superhero that I talked about it's
called a superhero by design unlike the
semiotics of super here with superheroes
and yeah so like I do like some some
formal and critical analysis of the work
too right now I'm like I'm really into
the into the making because honestly I
reached more people you know the ten
people that are going to buy the book
that I won this award for 20 people
maybe you know that I like my my peers
you know that's not necessarily need to
speak to so I'm like you know so what i
strutted what i try to do is actually
work in a narrative structure because
we're made out of stories what are you
like it or not we just keep editing them
over and over again so a lot of my
energy is going that way because I know
that I can reach more people 6,000
people are not going to buy that book
that is told you about so that's that's
what my head is right now but I do that
kind of work too because it's like it
like talk about ideas and I love like
that type of the type of engagement that
um a lot of times it's in forming a
historically informing the work that
will make it so yes sir
thank you
that's one of the curious comics there's
room so inherently yes which is why the
reason I love yes yeah what the
experience was trying to extract pros
world some crossing medium as well as
transforming that to similar approach
yeah it's
it's so difficult that's the first day
cool so so here's the thing this is like
we working from our second graph of this
thing like they totally just tore to
pieces like this other alternative view
of the story that we were trying to put
out because first thing was like point
of view right we're thinking like okay
well if people gonna buy this adaptation
obviously they've already read kindred
right no not so much because here's the
thing the people that actually got us to
do that particular job had just stumbled
across octavia butler had just found her
it's woman a wonderful editor Sheila
Kenan she was still at abrahams comic
artists work who's putting it out she
came across her and she's been working
in publishing for like 20 30 years 20
years you know and not heard of this
particular dissing writer right and the
president of the company was taken a
night class and came across the
narrative so I say I like to say is that
we had to readjust up approach and pull
out some of the more visceral parts of
it it's very difficult because even in
the sketches the brutality of the store
is a very dark narrator it's not I feel
good anything you know and so I find
myself trying to I'm it's very difficult
we talking about like okay how do you
what panels do you describe a whipping
through you know that kind of thing you
know like oh my god it was like five
whippings are in the story so so trying
to pull out those narratives and
actually trying to figure out like
spatially how these things are working
and then also using the affordances of
comics like diagrammatically because
there's one Pig report we're like Dana
the main character has like this bag and
so we use cutaways and things that
comments do really well diagrammatically
to tell the story so for instance of
things happen example simultaneously on
various floors we have things like that
that comics do really well I like your
comment about like the multimodal nature
of comics too because one of the things
I really love about them you know is
that they can talk about reading in
various ways easily because they cannot
synthesis to a certain degree of image
and text you know and that's one of
things I always push I'm talking to
teachers like okay well when I really
taught how to read those types of images
early on unless you're in a program like
this
right and why is that I'm always leery
about that like why are people not
trained to read images that way early on
like as kids you know that kind of thing
and our comments can be a facilitator
for that so it's been very difficult I
think the process of doing the
breakdowns of the pages has been very
helpful in pulling out the right the
right images so what I'm doing right now
is I'm drawing the entire book as
sketches right the entire put them on
page 198 right now it's 240 page book so
what's happening is I'm doing the
breakdowns Damon's gonna do lettering
all that stuff has to be redone right
but we're still knowing exactly what the
framing mechanism is going to be there's
a whole part of stories there had to be
edited out that we just could not deal
with you know because the book is
actually longer than a graphic novel
right so i think the heart of the story
is going to be there but it's a very
difficult trans trans latian in them i'm
happy to be doing it but I'm I don't
know if I want to do that kind of thing
Israel there's a lot of pressure to
because it's a beloved book you know so
hope that answered your question right
yes sir
that's why i like to make the students
uncomfortable I do I knew because i
don't i really don't bite my tongue
about the political aspects of what
design does and we were talking about
this earlier how like essentially i'm
teaching people how to manipulate people
right i mean graphic design for the most
part is in service of you know
capitalism and all that good stuff and
i'm giving them the tools to to sell
things to people and so i was talking
earlier about like creating the first
ethics course at university illinois it
was called edge epic sort of the
designer in a global economy we're
thinking about from various types of
ethical standpoints okay so who are you
working for why are you working for this
person outside of just paying for your
absorbed at student loans how are you
going to keep your sanity how are you
going to actually keep you manatee and
work in this particular industry because
eats ideas buy candy eats them you know
spits it back out at you that's what it
does really well you know and i'm glad i
didn't going to like the corporate
sector I've actually seen what happens
to someone that goes into the corporate
sector like that I was talking to his
gentleman he was the first
african-american to have like a really
successful advertising company and but
he has this book called called brainwash
to write and he talks about the power of
images particularly around like you know
the black image and so these types of
ideas I do bring into it I bring it to
the into the classroom and say okay look
I'm presenting these things to you you
know so you'll know once you're going
out there trying to get a job in the
image creation industry because that's
what they're doing you're manipulating
images and sell these things of people
so I do make people uncomfortable you
know purpose because I do believe in a
little discomfort we talking about
learning you know because they're safe
as safe as I oh it's going to be cool
but I try to do things are more thematic
like for instance some in my applied
semiotics course I change the theme up
from time to time like right now the
theme listen I'm not teaching that
course right now next year is probably
the call it primary don't like deal like
connotations of primary colors and the
students have to create their own own
products projects according to the
connotations of the colors you know
that's going to make them really
comfortable because it's still used to
like checking off boxes you know
no that doesn't really happen in my
classes actually it's a lot of like a
lot of wrestling with the problem
because it's visual that I'm teaching my
methodology of thinking you know so so
it just happens to have a deliverable
right but it's a thought process and
that's what I'm trying to teach them
about right now I'm teaching this course
called hip hop in visual culture because
I do like a lot of teaching around like
hip hop in and visual thinking and the
item just make them on the little cjs
like sampling remix ings constantly like
mixing up things and put them out there
into the world you know that's what it
doesn't we do and you're constantly you
know agitated by the stuff that you are
at you consume right so I try to have
like a really serious like media theory
like component to the courses but it
always ends up in a studio course with
something that's made I don't want them
to necessarily leave with a portfolio to
go get a gig honestly I rather that they
do other things but you know I think
that at the end of the day I want them
to be citizens who just happened to be
designers you know that's what I really
want I wanting to be like active
citizens who are makers of these things
and actually being very conscious about
what what they're doing ethically with
the work that they're making so now all
my classes sent around it idea
thank you